sommes avec arnaud benedetti rédacteur
en chef de la revue politique et
parlementaire bonsoir arnaud benedetti
merci d'être avec nous en tee shirt sur
rt france le président qui s'exprimera
lundi
qu'est ce que vous en attendez vous à ce
que vous en attendez quelque chose déjà
coûté le président de la république
s'est exprimé déjà des beaucoup depuis
le début du confinement les depuis le
début de cette pandémie
ce que l'on peut attendre du président
c'est que il s'engage disons dans une
démonstration un peu plus détaillée des
mesures qu'il entend prendre dans les
semaines qui viennent à la fois sur la
poursuite du kung fu nu du confinement
sur éventuellement peut-être les mesures
aussi de soutien à l'économie qui
aujourd'hui s'annonce absolument
indispensable compte tenu de la
situation d'un certain nombre de nos tpe
et pme
et puis éventuellement qu'ils engagent
des pistes sur la stratégie de
déconfinement qui sera celle disons
mises en oeuvre ou en tout cas penser
par les autorités publiques de ce pays
voilà ce qu'on peut attendre disons du
discours du président de la république
lundi prochain alors emmanuel macron qui
a décidé de consulter tous azimuts avant
de prendre ses décisions et de
s'exprimer lundi parmi ces consultations
une évidemment symbolique très remarqué
aujourd'hui celle du professeur raoul
qui est parfois controversés ça vous a
surpris les observateurs que vous êtes
cette visite
ce professeur vous savez l'idée raul
n'est pas controversé sur le plan
scientifique wilmer faciaux sa
production scientifique est une
production scientifique qui est
incontestable il publie dans les
meilleures revues à comité de lecture
il fait partie mais semblablement du
taur file des meilleurs virologue au
monde donc disons ça sa stature
scientifique est incontestable
ce qui est contesté en essais c'est la
méthodologie qui l'a mise en
pour tester le traitement qu'ils
proposent mais en fait le président de
la république a compris que l'idée raout
et est aujourd'hui l'un des seuls voire
peut-être l'un des rares voire l'un des
seuls scientifiques qui est médecin qui
était en mesure en tout cas d'apporter
une solution certes hypothétique à la
crise que nous connaissons
et comme le président de la république
est quelqu'un qui est capable de sentir
l'opinion et il a dû certainement
consulté un certain nombre d'études
d'opinion d'ailleurs qui sont parus et
qui ont repris et que le traitement dû à
tout cas les solutions composées par le
professeur out étaient des solutions qui
intéressait c'est le moins que le puisse
dire
une large partie de nos de nos
concitoyens il a compris que cette ce
déplacement à marseille était important
d'autant plus qu'il faut le rappeler
qu'un certain nombre d'élus je pense au
maire de nice je pense au président de
la région paca
je pense au président de l'exécutif
corse gilles simeoni ou et où un ancien
ministre de la santé quand philippe
douste-blazy appel à une généralisation
de ceux de ce traitement donc dans un
contexte qu'il veut être celui de
l'unité nationale il est important que
le président de la république envoie des
des signes adressent des messages à une
partie des grands élus et une partie de
l'opinion publique
est ce que nos bd des tilles les
français n'attendent pas davantage aussi
de de clarté
en cette quatrième semaine de
confinement strict notamment sur la
question des tests des masques aussi
avoir peut-être des encouragements sur
une stratégie de déconfinement alors que
je le répète à nos voisins européens eux
commencent à parler de déconfinement
nous eh bien c'est l'omerta comment vous
vous l'expliquer alors c'est pas tout à
fait l'omerta parce que le collet
ministre avait dix ont déjà parlé en
tout cas évoqué un certain nombre de
pistes possibles devant les
parlementaires sur la stratégie de
déconfinement et il lui a été reproché
d'ailleurs au 2e rang dans avoir parlé
vraisemblablement trop tôt en effet ce
qu'attendent aujourd'hui une partie de
nos compatriotes c'est des réponses
précises et pratiques sur les manques
sanitaires qui sont ceux aujourd'hui du
pays et que la crise a cruellement
illustré c'est à dire la question du
masque l'utilité ou non du masque la
question des tests parfaitement
totalement mais également la question de
la chloroquine qui se pensent des stands
de chloroquine donc on voit bien que sur
l'ensemble de ces de ses segments très
pratique jusqu'à présent
les présidents d'un public et l'exécutif
n'ont pas été en mesure d'apporter des
réponses précises tout simplement parce
que d'abord il ne sont vraisemblablement
pas tous d'accord sur une stratégie
disons de déconfinement en tout cas sur
les moyens d'opérer cette stratégie de
déconfinement et puis ensuite parce que
nous avons deux cruellement que sur le
plan sanitaire que la communication
d'ailleurs chaotique de l'exécutif n'a
pas été en mesure de dissimuler ses
moins qu'on puisse dire merci beaucoup à
nos benedetti d'avoir été avec nous en
direct sur arte france rédacteur en chef
de la revue politique et parlementaire